my next guest my next guest just won the
outstanding chef award from the james
beard foundation he's here today with
some recipes from his newest restaurant
china poblano at the cosmopolitan of las
vegas please welcome jose andres jose
good to see you good to see you
conan how are you old friend i'm doing
great you got a lot of energy i like you
you're good i'm gonna make a cocktail
for you
a what a cocktail a cocktail yes okay
i'll roll them with my accent or what no
it sounded strange but uh cocktail we're
going to make a cocktail
and tell us what kind of cocktail we're
going to make blackened decker
coconut cocktail
another corporate plug tonight all right
another one okay
what kind of cocktail is this why would
we need this okay i have no idea
you are in a beautiful beach in the
caribbean no i'm not i'm in a studio
you are you have to imagine okay i'm
imagining i'm in a beautiful beach you
have a coconut
right in the beach yes and you don't
know what to do with it
right okay you you bring with you you're
black and decker
wait a minute let's go to beach i'm on a
beautiful beach and i'm standing there
and i've got a black
knock on that guy okay are you shouting
at me
okay all right you're too excited okay
okay and then
you know that they have like two eyes
and a mouth
that's why i think the coconuts always
speak to you oh yes yes
yeah everyone knows yes of course they
look like people yes
of course they do and when they come
down from the trees because they feel
alone
and they want to talk to people and you
think the coconuts
want to talk to you i think so okay all
right
i know you opened their mouth okay okay
what are you gonna do look at
you put it right there in the mouth
oh yeah okay
okay
comfort with your hand wait okay i'm
good i got it i got that yeah wow okay
okay and now you're gonna take the
coconut water out all right
some of the water i think it'll come out
faster if i make two holes actually that
let's get it running so that's the
problem
will come out right everybody
oh man you're good you've done that
before
do you want to do one do more no but now
they're not gonna talk to you
you you made that hole in the eye ah
that got my finger
it's only on the mouth all right okay i
don't know what you're talking about
all right so show is so broken uh all
right so where do i pour this i pour out
a little actually yeah put it there a
little bit
and now we're gonna make the cocktail
you've already lost interest in your
chicken can i do this
what's that some broom rum oh come on
yeah you do it all right
some um what is this bitters
what's that yeah bitters theaters
beaters what are i don't even know what
bitters are
me no either uh yeah beetles maybe no
either syrup you do it do this here okay
like that like that man you're good okay
and now you're gonna shake it
do we have music here yeah yeah okay
music no we can't afford that
jake powder oh
we forgot we forgot what we forgot quick
open the
ah the coconut water come on what what
you're the one that's supposed to be
telling me
oh but i don't have the recipe in front
of me here again shake it shake it
okay no more shaking too much too much
you just told me do more shaking and i
know too much
take a look what's happening to your
hair is checking too much okay all right
okay now
we're going to strain it into this glass
okay quick
no that's okay right there all right
beautiful okay
and now he's the cool oh i forgot the
rum
what man okay no we poured a lot of no
but you didn't put rome in mine
oh okay come on cover my back okay so
grab this the syringe why do we have a
syringe
because it's cool you come to the beach
with the black and decker and the
syringe
yeah that's going to look real natural
walking on the beach with a surreal
some of this amazing cocktail into the
syringe
okay and this is very normal you can do
this nothing came in this is not okay
can you do it again
yeah i can do it again what it's not
going in i don't know what the problem
is oh yeah because you didn't
take away the condom the thing the cover
come on man
are you with me yeah i'm with you yeah
right okay and then
look at how beautiful he's like a baby
he's like a
baby boy such a weirdo
you fill up the coconut with a cocktail
okay so i i j okay this is oh this feels
so
weird open your mouth
open open you can do this too
oh man it's cool that is pure
that is pure and then that's it you put
the straw i'm gonna put more in okay
okay go yeah yeah you're getting dirty
careful yeah okay okay
there we go then what the straw start
right
good we have here we've been here ladies
yeah
yeah you like more confidence yeah that
would go well
we have to move we have one more thing
we got another thing to do what are we
gonna do how much time we have okay
we've got no time here take a look at
this oh yeah what is that
happy buddha happy buddha okay so i did
the dessert we got to do this fast
happy buddha taking a bath happy buddha
taking a bath that's what we're gonna
make take a look at this here
is the hedge of the buddha okay try to
take one head out okay
and these are the feet and hands of the
buddha these are uh molds and this is
the gelatin that's coming out of them oh
the feet look at okay beautiful all
right okay put the head on the plate
this is the head yeah that's the head of
a buddha give me a hand yes look at that
look at him
[Applause]
all right okay that's the head of the
buddha right there these are the feet
and here we have the belly okay and
here's his pancreas
right here and here we have the air
of lychees okay and then we're gonna
cover
the lychee around the buddha and don't
tell me that this doesn't look
like buddha taking a bath
wait that's buddha taking a bath yeah
you know put it there put it there blend
it what is this blend oh we're gonna
blend it yeah
you're blending doing everything in the
wrong order i know but i wanted to make
sure we finish it on time that's how you
make the
the foam the air okay so this is we do
this beforehand
this is the craziest cooking segment
we've ever done
well i mean you people told me make
something fun for coffee this is great
yum hey no problem you got the rum
yeah the buddha might start to make
sense if i've got the rum oh
yeah oh we have oh this is great
let's get a nice shot of that oh there's
buddha buddha
that one is more beautiful yeah oh this
one
this one looks like buddha at a crime
scene
yeah but he's so happy
you bring it back to life that is
fantastic that it's very good
it's strawberry you want to try this
this is really good right
i'm sure yeah i'll eat i'll eat some
buddha yeah
but look at how cute is the head what's
that the the head is so
cute i mean he says smiling almost looks
like you
but in in buddha yeah do you have a
place to sleep tonight by any chance
can they stay yeah you can stay hey you
want to stay here hey you see what the
ladies
all right well that is uh
thank you so much for being here uh
check out the bazaar
right at the uh sls hotel beverly hills
and gina poblano in las vegas jose
andres thank you very much